and it's time to do our draft for today
the schedule has been out since April
but as the season is upon us now is the
time to predict the best games of the
season and this is very open-ended
there's 256 to choose from we will go
back and forth Chris as always we have
this beautiful three shot here the coin
in the middle call it in the literal
digital air how does it feel to be the
third most handsome guy on this graphic
right here just just tails tails tails
tails just crown me now stats it's over
you see it you guys want to just cut to
commercial cuz this is not even worth
watching domination here we go well
we've already proved that over and over
again the easy first pick I'm going to
take thy fans to week 9 where thy Aaron
Rogers will be playing by Tom Brady in
New England that is what I'm excited for
what that's all I gotta say 12 verse 12
I mean it's goat verse goat and we have
only got to see this one time before in
Green Bay a few years back on a four
o'clock game in the afternoon on a
Sunday and it was a pretty awesome game
that day and I expect the same but yes
we have not seen Aaron Rodgers up in New
England in his career the last time the
Green Bay Packers went up there he was
hurt for that match up so that is my
number one I just can't wait to see that
it's two of my favorite quarterbacks of
all time I know some people think I
don't like Tom Brady because I won't say
he's the greatest of all time I'm such a
bad person
no but I think I cheated well that's why
people think you don't like him could
you say he cheated well yeah he did he
took the air of the football he should
has admitted that because he was awesome
in Super Bowl xlix two weeks later and
he showed us that when the air is
properly in the football he is pretty
amazing well look that was the
no-brainer top game of the year it's an
NBC game Sunday Night Football coming up
week nine but you know that this one is
a close second I will concede that
because you you guessed the coin toss
right you got the clear-cut number one
game of the year a game that we talked
about from time to time a game that
still resonates a game that that helped
derail the Steelers season the Steelers
in the Patriots getting together in
Pittsburgh week 15 just like last year
it was a great game last year will be a
great game again this year and it may go
a long way toward determining where the
rematch happens if the rematch happens
last year the rematch didn't happen I
think in part because the Steelers knew
they were gonna have to go to New
England they had no chance there they'd
have to beat the Steelers in Pittsburgh
to have a chance to force the Patriots
to come to town to have a chance to get
past the Patriots Chris it certainly
will be monumental for the AFC playoff
picture we get that and it's gonna be a
big matchup I think you could have done
better
I've seen better I'm very glad I didn't
take it take the one I should have taken
boss take one right from this week week
one okay we got Jon Gruden verse mini
Jon Gruden the Rams and the Raiders I
just can't wait to see that one because
the Rams have all these star players
that we've yet to see play so I want to
see that unveiled John Gruden's run like
four plays the whole preseason like the
same four plays over and over so I can't
wait to see his offense I mean he's done
nothing I think he's gonna unleash the
kitchen sink on everybody on Monday
Night Football and I mean this is his
protege in a Shawn McVeigh that I mean
you have you ever heard I look at Gruden
there's Gruden with the Chuckie I there
is McVeigh there that look at that
they're like they're like twinsies
sometimes you ever hear Shawn McVeigh
talk I sometimes don't know if it's
McVeigh or Gruden who's talking if I
couldn't see who it is so I am truly
intrigued by this game I think it's
gonna be a lot of fun of course it's the
Raiders back in Oakland Jon Gruden
Chucky's back in town and it's Hollywood
LA coming up so I know it's week one but
I think it's pretty damn good but don't
you think the Kaleo Mac trade takes a
lot away from that game I mean it
certainly takes a little bit there's no
doubt but I don't think the Raiders
defense was ever gonna be the theme of
this football game so I don't know
that's why but I still I like the
coaching matchup I think it's personal I
think the you know what do I want to say
the teachers want to want to teach the
student a lesson or the what the the
what's the old line from the old police
song the servant becomes the master or
something like that turn your face
alabaster when you find your servant is
your master
you'll be wrapped around my finger you
will probably like in diapers when that
song
Kame I don't even know what you're
talking about of course you never do all
right you got the right idea because
there gonna be some great NFC West AFC
West games this year you picked the
wrong one though because I am gonna go
south of the border Mexico City Chiefs
getting together later the Chiefs are
what the Raiders wish they could be the
issue because the Chiefs have Patrick
mahomes so that's the better game so you
blew it round two Chris Sims
give me that Mexico City game Rams
Chiefs and there's gonna be some people
in LA saying hey they want us to come to
these games why didn't he leave this one
at the Coliseum this is the one to see
you're gonna have to go to Mexico to see
it I got that that will be a good game
certainly because you're riding this
Patrick mahomes I mean you're gonna ride
this till you die huh that's what you're
gonna do just he's involved you want to
tune in because when he's a star I will
never shut up about that we know that
that is true
I still think you could have done better
here man I got so many games to choose
from and I'm dominating so badly right
okay then just pick pick the next one
surely you've got number three on your
list if I've screwed up too then you
should be able to get one two three so
go ahead and take it
yep I'm gonna take it I'm gonna go to
week 16 Steelers verse Saints that's
what you know why I like this cuz well
it's Chris Sims is Super Bowl 53 matchup
that's why I got my eye on I think we're
gonna see a preview very late in the
year of what we could see in the first
weekend of February but the Steelers we
know there are a team on the mission
their defense I think is extremely good
yes I know levy on bail is not there but
the offense is still really good too
they're still gonna be one of the 10
best offenses I don't care if Le'Veon
Bell plays this year or not and I think
they're I think they're the cream of the
crop in the AFC and I look at the Saints
and I go man one of the best offensive
lines of the sport drew Brees Alvin
Kamara Sean Payton and their defense has
some young studs on it too I think we're
seeing a Super Bowl preview right there
in week 16 leading into the playoffs
that game itself could have implications
of a one-seater at
seed affecting if either one can get to
the Super Bowl so that's when I got my
eye on for sure well there was a playoff
game last year here in Philadelphia the
NFC Championship game the final score
suggested a blowout the reality is a lot
closer than that it was a few plays here
they are early on that went the wrong
way for the Vikings the right way for
the Eagles and the next thing you know
the game was over but this year they get
together week five and there we know
there's gonna be one different
quarterback in Kirk Cousins and there's
probably gonna be two different
quarterbacks because I think Carson
Wentz will be back by then so it's gonna
be a very different game high stakes
though four teams are trying to position
themselves for division championships
and potential playoff buys this is one
of those games that's gonna echo into
January when it comes time to figure out
who is gonna be playing at home who's
gonna be playing on the road and it's
just it's the Vikings are gonna come in
here I think determined to try to
rectify what went wrong for them in the
NFC Championship game yeah and I do
think that the interesting thing with
that football game is like as Carson
Wentz back in the fold at that point is
that gonna be his second game back his
first game back what will it be where
the Eagles gonna be at this point
so those storylines are all in the fold
here yeah I mean I get you there's no I
can't even hate on you but that pic
that's a pretty good one I mean pretty
do we want to go one more round
yes we do okay well I'll go I'll go
first
I man gosh there's two games that really
jump out to me go pick one okay I got to
go with the Steelers and the Jags week
11 I got to do it because I mean
especially with Jalen Ramsey saying Ben
Roethlisberger's you know overrated and
all of those things and I just look at
the Steelers you're gonna go are you
kidding me they're gonna go down to
Jacksonville I think they're gonna feel
cheated the Steelers are used to
bullying football teams that's what the
Steelers do and they were bullied twice
last year by the Jacksonville Jaguars
and I just think that will set itself up
for really one of the most physical
hard-hitting best trash-talking best
endzone dance an interception picking
type of football game we could see this
year it might not always be pretty but
we're gonna see a lot of old school
physical football you know I know what
you were torn between you went with one
AFC playoff rematch you left the other
one on the shelf and that would be
coming up just next week the Jaguars and
the Patriots get together again and
these rematches I think mean more when
it's early in the year I think it's it's
easier to pick up the fumes of the last
time the team's got together you get
deep into the season it's not as
important early on Jags Patriots the
Jaguars had that game won they're up 20
to 10 there was the bad call on the
miles Jack forced fumble where it should
have been ruled in real time a fumble
and a touchdown
the Jaguars got possession but they
didn't get the 65 yards they should have
gotten much easier than what Blake
bortles could have earned for them which
was not nearly 65 they ended up having
to punt and that opened the door for the
comeback that's a huge game and the
Jaguars are going to have a major major
chip on their shoulder to try to finally
get past the Patriots yeah the Jaguars
had some matchups on yeah I wanted to
pick the Jaguars like three or four
different times I mean this week we
could have picked the Giants Jags this
week with just the Jalen Ramsey Odell
matchup and all those things in it
here's the other one I mean I really
wanted to pick Mike was the Rams and the
Chargers the battle for LA in week three
I truly am intrigued by that I mean I
was out there a few weeks ago and I do
think there's a part of LA people who
are still kind of trying to figure out
who they want to root for some feel
spurned by the Red Raiders that's who
they root for I found that out too
that's what was crazy you're right some
of them do root for the Raiders so but I
do think this battle could go a long way
and to swaying that in-between fan that
would be then maybe my if we had a 5th
around that would have been my pick
wellnot 5th round based on four round
stats what do we have this was very
close I'm giving Mike the edge because
not only did you pick good games Mike I
like the storylines that went along with
your games Patriots Steelers the rematch
of that controversial finish that you've
been talking about all show Vikings
Eagles is a playoff rematch
I like that Chris you have good games
you don't have as many juicy storylines
as Mike does so I'm like I'm giving you
the slight edge congratulations you win
do i this do I get to do I'd get to take
home rocky is that mine is that the
trophy for today does it matter
we should make this the PFT live draft
trophy
I just keep it all this you know I got
no problem with you winning the draft I
got a problem with stats logic sometimes
what's the problem well I mean no
storylines let me see I said better
storyline whatever just talk about it
you always have a problem with stats
logic when you lose I have a problem I
open up that without going this was very
close I want to hear him do that one
time without it that's what I want to
hear it one time but it's supposed to
make you feel better it's kind of like
your participation it doesn't make me
feel better unless I win I don't
you